卒論が
ひとまず
完成したいや一応完成したんですけどここからなんですよ
関東も今日ずに見せたり猫もみたいな人に見せベルしてそこでしっかり修正して怜音
学校に提出して初めて即興分ができたっているので穴足まで来ないという複雑な同居
っとパパで複雑な同郷
中複雑な状況でちょっと質問コーナーでいきますはい今後
はたくさんの応募ありがとうございました女性一発目のちゃんと作動が何でちょっと
適当に怒って1に下がっていきますよで愛子
hec し地下ひっです
だめだ量産できないから覚醒してくれこれダメとにかく全力でもらってください
あああああ
ポーズ早食いん
始めショタは好きかい俺はショタだよん
そうなので m 入れよ質問なんかない花20円いく set 目られるかやって血が
出た最近さあ友達と導管と思ったことがあってそれがシュレック+鰹節これ始めまず
共感がメロン真面目な質問です二股してるわけじゃないんですが今好きな人がいるんで
元彼のことを忘れられませんどうすればいいのでしょうか
られるのははじめしかありません助けてください難しい質問ですねどう
いうことなんだろう好きな人がいるのに元彼のことが忘れられないということは舌上
2人が好きって感じかなあこれもどっちかは諦めでしかありませんね
難しいけど設けやったら色々もやっちゃうからひとまずどっちかなことを忘れるれてず
どっちかなことを忘れられるまでちょっと時間をおきましょうまずのも大事です赤結構
いいこと言ったよいまはじめの母ちゃんデベソ
やめとけ殺されるぞ俺の母さんに洗濯機に入ってくださいまじかまじか
肇社長はカモシカ夏の付き合っていたとしてある日家に帰ったら彼女は知らない男と出
ていた時の反応
なぁ
ん
うん
卒業ば分家してみてジャロアー
冗談でもだめだ充電して欲しいなら授業をとっててその水業の単位を取れないか無火事
た卒業できないのでその単位が取れていたかどうかは動画に出しますお楽しみに絶対に
7時に起きないといけないのに充電に起きたり役所も足りないね寝るよすべて使い
果たしてくらい全力でてください
どすこいどすこいターンそしてどすこいどすこいどすこい
タッパ通す声パッタ通すどうすごい濃い
通す公営声ダンスうっぱらっぱっぱらぱーん
なんてことしてくれた大根をカメラのごとく割る-7
これをれちゃった僕のチャンネルを三行で紹介料亭チャネルでは毎日うどんを食べると
か
はじめにずっと聞きたかったことがあるんだ夜も眠れず何日8
何年たったことかけどこの質問すれば私たちの中もどう変わるかをいろいろ想像
してしまうので怖いんですでも知りたいっていう強い思いを込めて決めました
naoto さんはじめの菩提を聞きたいだからストレートに言っちゃいます
始めどんなにつらくても正直に答えてください
コーラとファンタどっちが好きです中で舌を鼻につけてください
勃起も全部のずっと big チョコ俺がもっとビッグにしてやるぜ
なんか
鎧ね muses のメンバーにしてくださいどうぞ自分の顔を殴って気持ちいいって
言ってください
えっ
気持ちふざけんなよはじめリバースリバー
エボリューション目フリマ月まあ僕があるシック思った本当に選ばれるのかと親に相談
したらあんた
はじめが選んでくれるわけないでしょバカな事なんかしてないで勉強しなさいよ
園児は返事植木なさいとバカだ考えたってことは自分がよくわかってる
でも僕はやっぱ諦めることができないだってはじめが式てから元気でよろしい勉強する
意味って何ですか
国語は日本語がしゃべればいいし数学計算ができれば ecb かは別に必要ない社会
はニュース見てればいいし0号日本にいたら使わなくていいですよね勉強に追われるの
がわかりません一市長と思いますか勉強する意味っていうのはですねー
正直あんまりないと思います勉強
をすること自体に大きな意味はないんかもしれませんがしっかり神根取り組む姿勢と
いうのが大事だと思いますしっかり勉強するっていうそのがんばれる力がこの先に自分
がしたいことが出てきた時の頑張る力になるんじゃないのかな
わかんないけどこっち来ず頑張れる人って素敵だと思います頑張ってね僕のを寄せる
そうなんですねアルミ友達ませんどうしたらいいですか安心してくれ
俺もいないから傷がをの地鶏を弟さんに送信
慢性言ってんだかねマジかマジか送っちゃったよひかちん大イベントとロールを天秤に
かけたときどっちをしてましたばいちゃー
前半なく単なる取ってから倒れるそして復活すると思いきやしないでそのまま眠りに
つくその後はじめが起きることはなかった
なにこれつまんなんだよ今回ちょっと急ぎ足で行っちゃったんですけども
今回もねとてもたくさんのコメントありがとうございました宮城でまたいつか機会がで
もしようと思いますよかったらまたコメントお待ちしておりますじゃあ
ん
振った